the
um the handle of the hammer is being
pushed up this way that's bending the
ruler and it's forcing this end of the
ruler down onto the table and again it's
a pretty stable system
please don't use that you know i am
oh i was asking for that
[Laughter]
so today i want to talk about a pretty
basic
idea in physics and that's the idea of
vectors
now i guess mathematicians might try to
steal vectors from us but but they are a
tool that we use and and they help us
understand some of the physical concepts
that go on behind
physics
now the idea is pretty simple a vector
is something that has a size
and it has a direction so the symbol
that i'm going to use
is an arrow um so we can think about
things that are vector quantities in
everyday life so velocity is one of
these
vectors so when you talk about a
velocity you have a size
so if if
i'm traveling in a car at 30 miles per
hour
that's that's the magnitude or the size
of my velocity but the other important
part of it is the direction
so velocity contrasts with something
like speed
speed is just the number speed is just
the 30 miles per hour without the
direction
so when do we care about this well
um
let's say you're driving down the road
in in your car and you're traveling at
35 miles per hour
if you encounter a speed trap
that speed trap doesn't care what
direction you're going in they just want
to know if you're above that that magic
number 30 miles per hour which is the
speed limit
so in that case speed is all that
matters
but let's say i'm crossing the road
and i look up and i see a car traveling
at 30 miles per hour i care very much
whether it's going in the direction
towards me or the direction away from me
so
aside from
velocity
what other vector quantities might we
have well acceleration is one
acceleration has a direction it's just
the change in velocity over time
so another one is force
force obviously has a direction force is
just something that moves
a mass moves an object
so you can think of it as a push or a
pull
so if i push on this book i'm exerting a
force
and it's a vector because it has a size
and it has a direction i'm pushing it in
that direction
now
let's sketch this out so
here's my book
roughly speaking
so
let's imagine we're both pushing on this
book i'm pushing in this direction
and you're pushing in this direction
with about the same amount of force
well the neat thing about vectors is we
can take those arrows and add them up to
figure out in which direction that book
is actually going to move
so let me just borrow your vector and
and
shift it so it's up here
i can then add those vectors top to tail
and the resulting
force
is going to be in this direction
so what that says is that if i push this
way and you push that way
the book goes that way it goes straight
down the table we can actually get
newton's second law
so newton's second law is very simple
it's f equals m a
so it means that the force
is equal to the mass times the
acceleration so what i was just talking
about
about a force being something that
accelerates a mass
now because i'm talking about vectors
what you might see in a book is or at
least in in my notation which some
people call north american is we we put
a little arrow over these quantities
because force
and acceleration are both vectors they
both have um a size and they both have a
direction mass doesn't mass obviously
doesn't have any direction it's just a
number so if you look in a book
sometimes you might see
um symbols like that with arrows yeah so
sometimes if you look in a textbook
you'll see you'll see this notation or
maybe you'll see the vectors underlined
or often you'll see them in bold type
okay so all i'm doing here is tying a
piece of string around this hammer
on a good length
and now i'm going to use it to suspend
this hammer from this ruler over the
edge of the table what we're doing here
is just balancing
the ruler and the hammer
and that works pretty well that's pretty
stable right
we can actually take this a little
further
there you go
so it's not magic it's just physics
so what's happening here
well what's happening is that the sum of
all of the forces
on this system
is equal to zero
so we've got one force we've got gravity
pulling the head of this
hammer down
it's held here by the string so it's
pivoting around that so when this end
goes down this end goes up and that
pushes against this end of the
ruler
and what that means is that this end of
the ruler on the table gets pushed down
and so because the center of mass of
this system most of the mass is here
underneath the table
because the center of the mass is right
underneath here the whole system is
stable so all of those forces all of
those vectors sum to zero
and we get no acceleration
no change in the movement that's a
static system well so i've talked about
these forces but it's hard to kind of
visualize some of them because this
ruler being wooden is pretty stiff so
we'll do it again but we'll use a
floppier ruler and i have to shorten the
string a little bit okay so now all i'm
doing is i'm switching the type of ruler
that i'm using i've made the string a
little bit shorter and i probably can't
get it as close to the end of the table
this time
but what you can see
very clearly now is you can actually see
that force acting upwards it's bending
this ruler and so the um the handle of
the hammer is being pushed up this way
that's bending the ruler and it's
forcing this end of the ruler down onto
the table and again it's a pretty stable
system
let me try that again it's a pretty
stable system i can poke it and it's
gonna wobble a bit
i'm happy having my foot underneath
because i don't think it's gonna fall